- [Narrator] You might not think
copper is worth more than a penny,
but in today's global economy,
it's actually worth a lot.
For electric vehicles, windmill farms,
even the power grid
itself copper is essential
and in short supply.
- At the start of the next decade,
we're going to have a shortfall
of over 5 million metric tons.
- [Narrator] Here's why the
metal has become so important,
and how a severe shortage
is threatening the global
push toward electrification.
- Electrification
essentially means moving away
from relying so much on fossil
fuels for our energy needs.
- [Narrator] Copper is
critical to electrification
because it has the highest conductivity
of any non-precious metal.
That's important when trying
to make an electric car,
or windmill efficient so
electricity isn't lost in transit.
- So copper is actually
used in a great quantity
for these electric vehicles,
and other renewable energies much more so
than what you would use
in a traditional fossil fuel power plant
or traditional cars.
- [Narrator] EVs require
an estimated four times
as much copper as gas fueled cars.
Wind and solar farms also typically need
about twice as much copper
as coal power plants.
- Just to demonstrate
how much copper is needed
for electrification
by 2031 we're going to need
over 35 million metric tons of copper,
and supply on the other hands
is supposed to lack behind
at 30 million metric tons.
- For decades our nation has failed
to meet the climate crisis
with the urgency it demands.
- [Narrator] Kamala
Harris is talking about
the Inflation Reduction Act,
which has pumped federal funds
toward green energy and electrification.
(audience applauding)
- Through the law, you
basically get tax credits,
and also other support
if you are involved in
the making of, you know,
wind farms, or factories
that are making solar
components and whatnot.
And obviously since copper is
such a huge component of that,
it's helping the prices for that as well.
- [Narrator] In May, copper was trading
at a little over $3.50 cents,
a dramatic increase from previous years,
and those prices could continue to rise.
Goldman Sachs estimates that
demand for green uses of copper
drives 7% of global consumption today,
up from just 4% in 2020.
And we'll account for a whopping 47%
of total demand growth
between 2023 and 2040.
So it's no surprise that copper
is the word on mining leader's lips.
- Copper.
- Exciting copper development.
- We're choosing to prioritize copper.
(bus engine growling)
- [Narrator] It sparked a flurry
of consolidation in the industry.
Glencore, BHP, Rio Tinto, and Newmont
have all made moves to
buy up other miners.
- They've realized that copper
is going to be in such a huge need
over the next decade or so,
so they have decided to
instead go buy other miners
to get quick access to their deposits
and get them producing in
the market much faster.
- [Narrator] But all of this consolidation
can't create more copper.
To find more, companies
need to open new mines,
which is very expensive.
- [Mike] What we're not going to do,
is simply go out and
buy a stream of copper.
- [Narrator] Analysts
say that copper prices
would need to rise to
$15,000 per metric ton
to attract investment in new mines.
Today prices are around $8,000 a ton,
and starting a new mine can
take a prohibitively long time.
Deutsche Bank estimates that projects
that start applying for permits today
will take around 10 years
to reach first production.
- And that's just the permitting process,
that's not even getting
to the production part.
So just imagine how long
it would take for you
to get any single like mine
in the producing stage.
- [Narrator] Plus, new and current mines
have also faced heightened scrutiny
on environmental and social grounds.
- There is increasing amounts
of environmental unrest,
social unrest with regards
to them being online,
especially as we've seen
recently in some countries
when they're trying to do that.
(reporter speaking in foreign language)
- [Narrator] In response
to looming shortages,
some companies are looking
to change their products.
For example, Tesla is changing
the makeup of battery packs
to cut copper usage in their EVs.
- That means we need only about a quarter
as much copper in the car
as would be needed for a 12 volt battery.
- [Narrator] But these
changes may not be enough.
Electrification is only
expected to increase,
and with it demand for
this non-precious metal.
- And that's going to be a thing
that's going to define,
you know, commodity markets
for the rest of the decade.
And a lot of people are also saying that
this right now is the next big bull run
in commodity markets.